foreign
Atlanta hi Garrett what's up love it um
so I've read my wife and I for the last
10 years and I would say me probably
have been on the uh originally for about
10 years been on the Ramsey light uh you
know syndrome of the past two years
we've done a really good job of going
through financial peace and you know
really hitting it that hard in the last
year had a really good situation with my
income as far as I'm in sales so coming
January 2023 I'm gonna have to pretty
significant bonus from some really good
accounts that I landed last year so
um in looking at that we're going to be
able to pretty much wipe out most of the
debt that we have left in baby step two
besides the house
um and just trying to understand kind of
with another large chunk of money kind
of sitting there well congratulations
how much are you getting
uh should be probably pre-tax around 140
000 but good for you yeah so we'll see
what 100 Grand clearer then and you'll
be able to do some stuff how much debt
have you got not counting your house
because you said most of sort of kind of
so I don't know what you're talking
about yeah it's around basically
probably a little over thirty thousand
dollars so um 100 debt free
nothing but the house if you're at a 30
000 check
correct okay all right so why most of
them so why do most of sort of kind of
language then well I guess there's some
things obviously my wife and I have
communicated and talked about maybe
wanting to do which is potentially a
small little cash house upgrade right
paint the house kind of patio small
small okay but that's purchases that's
not debt right and so I really being in
being in sales I want to make sure that
I'm comfortable when you call it three
to six months I feel like if
commissioned as you know can go up and
down not three to six months of income
it's three to six months of expenses
okay right expenses don't go up and down
and then obviously what account to put
it in you always say money market is
that still the best option right now
considering the economy and everything
so you're not you're not trying to make
money with the emergency fund you're
trying to protect the things that are
making money
great and I I guess I need to get on my
Smart investor Pro because I need to
find somebody with a good mutual fund
situation so I'm sure you have a few of
those yeah just jump online and do that
but here's the thing you just here's
what I had to learn to do the first time
I got to check that size it's kind of
mind-blowing and our human tendency is
okay I'm gonna have a hundred thousand
so we in our mind we kind of spend 300
000. oh man right or 800 000 if you're
in the baloney house right and so you
got to back down and just go okay I'm
gonna take I'm gonna write down the
number 100. I'm going to take 30 out of
it and I'm 100 debt free I'm gonna take
25 out of it and I'm gonna have an
emergency fund and then I'm going to
allocate for home repairs actual home
repairs and actual bids we're not going
to accidentally take on more home
repairs than we have money
because I put you back in debt
okay but you need your emergency phone
in place and debt free and I'll call it
25 I just made that number up I don't
care what it is but that's 55 which
leaves you 45 and the kitchen and the
painting is 25 okay and so now I've
still got 20 and I can you know start
some investing for the kids college and
some stuff like that then with that and
we get to fix up the house and we paid
off all the debt and we have the
emergency fund all in one Fell Swoop but
if you don't freaking write it down
it'll blow up on you
understood and if a GC knows you have
I don't know around fifty thousand
dollars to spend they're gonna put a
hundred thousand dollar bid in front of
you and make it really hard to walk away
from yeah because there's a lot of stuff
you can do to a kitchen these days yes
and let me let me challenge you one more
take ten thousand of that off top and
give it away
oh definitely give some of that money
away I'll be tithing for sure and giving
let that be a spirit of
um first fruits man yeah generosity the
whole process